lala minec tome a is the
surgical removal of a part of the vertebra
known as the lamina the
vertebral column or backbone is composed
of 24 vertebrae each vertebra has two
laminae that together form the roof of
the spinal canal the lamina protects the
spinal cord in the
neck and back regions in the
lower back where the
spinal cord ends
the lamina protects the large bundle of
nerves known as the cauda equina
and the arak ideas nerve roots
compression of the nerve roots may be
due to osteophytes  caused
by arthritis herniated discs that
compress the nerve root or
less frequently bone tumors of
the vertebrae the lamina relieve
back and leg pain
caused by this compression of the
nerve roots by removing the lamina
in whole or in part this
immediately relieves pressure on the
nerve root in the presence of a
herniated disc from  In general, the doctor will
perform a discectomy through
which the cause of the compression is directly eliminated.
cervical vertebrae
micro my grandson mine and
microdisectomy are procedures that
are performed under a
microscope when you arrive at the hospital you
will have an intravenous line placed and
a catheter may be placed in
your bladder to drain urine moments
before  surgery you will be given
general anesthesia or
spinal anesthesia spinal anesthesia is injected into
a sac that surrounds the spinal cord and
numbs the area where the doctor
will work micro and administers
spinal anesthesia you will be awake
during the procedure but you will not feel
nothing in the lower half of your body
the atomic sheet takes between one and three
hours during the procedure you will be
placed in  ventral decubitus
face down or lateral position on the side
the surgeon will start by making a
small incision on the spine the
forceps are used to separate the fat
and muscle from the lamina with a
special bone drill
the surgeon will cut the lamina to be able to
see the canal  spinal cord and locate the cause
of the nerve compression if
the compression is caused by a herniated disc
the doctor will perform a discectomy to
remove the bulging disc to
complete the procedure
the deep tissues will be saturated and the incision in
the back
after surgery will be  you will be taken to
the recovery room for
monitoring the nurses will
regularly check your vital signs and
the strength of your leg on the side where you
had surgery to make
sure the nerve has not been
seriously injured you will be encouraged to
get up and walk around  as soon as you
feel well if you had a catheter inserted
before surgery the m  The same will be
removed before leaving the hospital.
If the discectomy
is uncomplicated, it is likely that you will be
discharged the day after
the operation. My regrets that are performed for
other reasons may require
longer hospital stays.